[Musique]
bonsoir mercredi 25 mars bienvenue dans
cette édition spéciale sur tv 78
neuvième jour de confinement pour
endiguer la crise sanitaire du
coronavirus la pandémie qui gagne du
terrain en ile de france
hier mardi 14 heures 587 cas
supplémentaires en 24 heures à noter que
seuls les cas graves sont aujourd'hui
testé pour désengorger les services
d'urgence et aussi éviter les
contaminations dans les cabinets
médicaux est la ville de poissy a ouvert
à partir d'aujourd'hui le kovy drôme
c'est un lieu de consultation dédiés aux
kobe de 19
il est situé avenue blanche de castille
au centre de diffusion artistique et des
espaces d'accueil et de consultations
ont été aménagés concrètement sur place
et des médecins volontaires ausculteront
des personnes présentant les symptômes
du coronavirus ces patients auront été
orientée par le 15 ou par leur médecin
traitant
très important donc il ne faut pas se
rendre sur place directement parmi les
individus à risque notamment les
personnes âgées nous vous parlions hier
de la situation rencontrée par l'ehpad
de parquets des dames à saint germain en
laye où il y aurait eu 14 décès parmi
les résidents et aussi sept salariés
contaminés à ce jour le groupe korian
qui gère cet établissement confirme une
situation grave sur place par la voix de
son porte parole situation grave comme
dans d'autres ehpad de france pas de
confirmation ni démenti pour autant des
chiffres donnés aucun décompte n'a été
réalisée par souci de discrétion pour
les familles des victimes et les
personnels soignants concernés
korian indique que les familles sont
informés quotidiennement et directement
et que des mesures de confinement sont
observées dans les chambres avec des
gestes barrières respecter le
confinement justement se poursuit me
viennent jour en france avec des règles
qui évolue pour les sorties une nouvelle
attestation de déplacement dérogatoire
est à présenter aux forces de l'ordre
les précisions de nicolas landry et bien
grégory voici la nouvelle attestation de
déplacement dérogatoire un document
édité par le ministère de l'intérieur et
que vous pouvez retrouver sur le site
interieur.gouv.fr cette nouvelle
attestation a fait suite aux annonces et
aux précisions apportées par le premier
edouard philippe par rapport aux mesures
du confinement
par exemple on retrouve des nouveaux un
motif comme la convocation judiciaire ou
administrative ou la participation à des
missions d'intérêt général sur demande
de l'autorité administrative
autre précision en lien avec l'activité
physique
ce déplacement devrait être bref dans la
limite d'une heure quotidienne et dans
un rayon d'un kilomètre autour de votre
domicile
dernière nouveauté il faudra préciser
l'horaire de sortie mais la seule règle
qui reste la même c'est bien de rester à
votre domicile
nicolas landry avec jules grevy halle
pour les moyens techniques et si vous
avez déjà imprimé l'ancien modèle le
ministère de l'intérieur indique que
vous pouvez l'utiliser tout de même en
ajoutant dessus de manière manuscrite
votre heure de sortie
le confinement qui continue de
bouleverser la vie des habitants depuis
hier sauf dérogation du préfet les
marchés sont interdits sur le territoire
une décision qui n'est pas sans impact
sur les producteurs et vendeurs dans les
yvelines certains se sont déjà
réorganisé c'est le cas de la ferme de
la haye qui a décidé de livrer
directement à domicile les clients qui
lui passaient commande un nouveau
service apprécié comme ont pu le
constater mélanie poquet et nicolas
kirillovitch quand il est interdit
d'aller au marché c'est le marché qui
vient à vous c'est une première pour
emmanuel bono habituellement vendeuses
sur les marchés elle est depuis ce matin
devenu livreur de produits frais à
domicile au programme de la tournée
aujourd'hui une quinzaine de clients la
livraison permet d'écouler une partie du
stock des fruits et des légumes bio
d'ordinaire vendus sur le marché de
maurepas elle les clients eux sont
évidemment ravis de pouvoir accéder à
des produits frais tout en restant à la
maison je tenais absolument dans la
mesure du possible à avoir toujours des
produits frais a pas être obligé de
manger que des concerts des pâtes du riz
non c'est très important d'avoir des
produits frais c'est aussi important de
les faire continuer à travailler
travailler en respectant les règles
sanitaires pour sa première tournée de
livraison emmanuel prend toutes les
précautions d'usagé
donc ça c'est ma belle mère qui a
confectionné
101 c'est une règle d'hygiène pour moi
ça me protège de ces rations les clients
les grands pareil la machine à carte
bleue qui va être deux ans à peu près
chaque livre iv c'était de surprenant de
nouveau avec des masques ou des choses
comme ça mais faut se protéger pour
satisfaire l'ensemble de ses clients aux
yvelinois la firme de là et prévoit
plusieurs livraisons par semaine radis
salades des poireaux viendront jusqu'à
vous le temps du confinement
il n'y a pas que les producteurs qui
livrent des denrées alimentaires les
chefs cuisiniers aussi se mobilise en
cette période pour concocter des plats
pour le personnel soignant impliqués
dans la lutte contre le coc vide 19
plusieurs ont répondu présent à l'appel
des toques françaises une association
qui promeut la gastronomie sur le
territoire parmi eux jean christophe
broux dix cuisiniers de la république de
maurepas il est rattaché au collège
guillaume apollinaire de plaisir il nous
explique sa démarche
marie ce bureau qui est la présidente
des toques françaises et guillaume gomez
qui est aussi le président des
cuisiniers de la république et qui est
le chef de l'elysée nous envoyer des
mails si deux simultanément pour nous
demander si on pouvait répondre
favorablement à une quelque chose qui
était mis en place d' améliorer le
quotidien des personnels hospitaliers
cyr change un petit peu du menu qu'ils
ont l'habitude d'avoir si on pouvait
alors à une petite partie gastronomique
au niveau des repas en évitant bien sûr
des repense aussi parce qu'on sait que
ces gens là ne peuvent pas s'asseoir la
plupart du temps pour soigner le
personnel qui les gens qui sont malades
le personnel ne peut pas s'asseoir dans
qui vaut justement lors emmené quelque
chose qu'ils vont pouvoir manger
facilement donc aujourd'hui on est dans
une je dirais une petite des marges tout
en entrant de contacter certains
fournisseurs alimentaire pour qu'on
puisse répondre farrar noblement à 7
cette initiative qui mis en fin de
compte sur les yvelines et sur toute la
france parce que vous avez des chefs et
des grands chefs comme michel sarran qui
aussi d'autres chefs qui font pas partie
des tops qui réponde favorablement à ce
qu'on a mis un petit peu en place avec
l'étape française et pourquoi vous vous
êtes lancé du coup dans l'initiative
pourquoi essayer d'y répondre
favorablement
alors moi j'ai toujours
ce prix vous savez très bien des
concurrents de service je le fais j'ai
d'autant en intérêts plus personnels
il ya quelques années je dirais
l'hôpital mignot a sauvé la vie mon
épouse j'ai aussi le membre d'une amie
qui travaille là bas je connais ces
conditions très difficiles très
particulière de je me suis dit que
c'était bien justement de leur apporter
un petit peu de réconfort
j'ai eu l'occasion de discuter un petit
peu avec elle ils sont tout à fait ravi
déjà des petites démarches ont été
faites par des boulangers ne meurt pas
avec qui je connais donc on est des
dépeint des choses comme ça mais cirque
aujourd'hui on voudrait vraiment les
ramener un petit peu un réconfort parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est une lutte h 24
justement pour soigner un petit peu tous
les tous les patients qui sont là bas
aussi on vient justement sur la démarche
de concocter des plats pour le personnel
soignant vous le disiez vous êtes vous
en phase de démarrage c'est le début de
la de cette phase pour pouvoir proposer
certains tout à fait avoir la honte en
phase de démarrage on a bien sûr
contacter des entreprises de maurepas il
ya des logistiques un petit peu amer
parce qu'aujourd'hui compte tenu d'un
petit peu du jeu dit elle on peut pas
faire ce qu'on veut donc qu'ils peuvent
pas non plus on est des traces de
traçabilité du frais bien sûr à sortir
et 6,6 produit justement peut pas livrer
n'importe comment il faut comme garantir
une sécurité alimentaire au niveau du
personnel j'ai un ami qui a un
laboratoire de traiteur qui aujourd'hui
est prêt justement à me prêter son
laboratoire pour pouvoir établir ses
plats dans les meilleures conditions et
bien sûr pouvoir les transporter dans
les meilleures conditions
c'est qu'aujourd'hui depuis vendredi on
a avancé beaucoup en attente de trois
réponses qui devrait arriver dans les 24
48 heures justement pour avoir des
denrées alimentaires et pouvoir répondre
favorablement à cette demande qui fait
justement pas aussi les hôpitaux de
paris mais l'objectif c'est de le mettre
en place dans un premier temps pour le
personnel de mignot c'est peut-être
aussi que d'autres confrères cuisinier
répondre favorablement à l'appel dans
les yvelines que ce soit tout le
territoire qui soit peut-être couleurs
voilà cirque aujourd'hui cet appel est
ni mention millions il ya un autre
collègue qui s'occupe de paris mais
j'irai mention des yvelines ya plein de
pitot qui ont besoin de ce genre de
choses aujourd'hui je sais qu'il ya des
chefs
on a lancé un petit peu les
par les convocations pour ce qu'ils
pouvaient répondre favorablement s'est
répandue sur les yvelines et bien sûr ça
répandues sont tout le territoire
français
là où il ya des hôpitaux jean éviter que
des chefs libre que moi justement pas un
petit peu s'investir tout en respectant
bien sûr les consignes et depuis la
réalisation de l'interview
jean-christophe broudie a pu récupérer
des denrées notamment grâce à auchan
maurepas lé préparation et livraison
pour les hôpitaux ont démarré et vont
pouvoir se poursuivre pendant plusieurs
jours bravo à lui et si vous souhaitez
vous aussi aider le monde médical le
personnel soignant soutenir aussi lé
projet de recherche ainsi que les
acteurs de terrain et les associations
l'opération tous unis contre le virus
vient d'être lancé par à l'ap-hp la
fondation de france et l'institut
pasteur est les dons collectés seront
précieux pour financer notamment du
matériel la recherche pour mieux
comprendre le coronavirus ou encore
l'accompagnement des personnes les plus
vulnérables les dons sont à faire en
priorité par internet
le confinement impacte forcément le
nombre de bénévoles pour les
associations ce qui n'empêche pas les
distributions solidaire de se poursuivre
au secours populaire des yvelines on
modifie la manière de partager les dons
avec les bénéficiaires le reportage de
mélanie poquet et d'aurélien nous on n'a
pas des manettes et l'un des enfants
aussi c'est le contrat que je reçoive
aujourd'hui un message pour me confirmer
la distribution d'arrêt aux libraires
alors que j'aime m'y attendrai même pas
un soulagement du côté des bénéficiaires
l'antenne de trappes continue ses
actions auprès de 100 familles ce
jour-là une demi douzaine de bénévoles
s'est rassemblée pour distribuer des
sourires malgré les masques et un autre
engagement pour certains non non moi je
m'occupe surtout les vacances des
enfants et les familles mais là dans
l'urgence faut des bras donc
il faut donner un coup de main parce que
malgré la crise les gens continuent de
manger les gens qui sont difficultés
sont doublement difficulté mais les
équipes ont dû s'adapter mise en place
de règles strictes des lignes au sol à
ne pas dépasser et de nouvelles
techniques de distribution
ici les bénévoles sont passés au drive
on a effectivement fait des colis plus
gros parce qu'on n'est pas sûr d'être en
capacité d'avoir assez de bénévoles pour
maintenir les distributions parce que
beaucoup des bénévoles sont des
personnes âgées et à risque et donc
confinées chez elles
l'ensemble des bénévoles portent des
masques des gants et on a dû les droits
alcoolique à disposition avec ed de
l'eau de javel de l'alcool ménagé pour
pouvoir vraiment tenté au mieux
d'éradication virus et des distributions
qui continue dans les yvelines comme ici
à saint cyr l'école
le secours populaire des yvelines
réfléchit aussi à apporter un
accompagnement scolaire par téléphone ou
visioconférence télétravail ou garde
d'enfants pour les salariés le siège
départemental fermer le secours
populaire français des yvelines connaît
la même situation que bon nombre
d'entreprises mais les structures
locales restent ouvertes
le point avec le secrétaire général du
département interrogé par mélanie poker
on a une quinzaine de structures locales
quand même qu'ils sont en capacité
d'assurer des dépannages alimentaires
plus ou moins importants selon les
villes et selon les forces en présence
s'il faut continuer à être présent pour
les bénéficiaires bah il faut dans la
mesure du possible et puis sans mettre
en danger les personnes non plus puisque
on a déjà quelques cas de personnes qui
restent chez elles parce que soit le
sont dans une tranche d'âge un petit peu
plus à risque que les autres soit parce
qu'elles craignent pour leur santé ce
qu'on peut comprendre c'est quand même
un petit peu anxiogène toutes ces
affaires là et puis on essaye de ne pas
prendre les choses à la légère du tout
il faut assurer les questions aussi
d'hygiène par exemple conflans sainte
honorine
on a été obligé de fermer puisque les
locaux se tourne sous sols faiblement
aéré malgré tout et quand ils reçoivent
le public c'est dans une salle qui est
traitée qu'à mise à disposition par la
mairie et la mairie par sécurité a fermé
tous ses espaces du coup les amis sont
bloqués peuvent pas peuvent pas aider
quoi on n'a jamais trop de bénévoles
puisque plus on a de bénévoles et plus
on peut diversifier les missions donc en
fait c'est sûr que l'on va essayer de
maintenir une bonne qualité de soutien
sur l'alimentaire parce que c'est quand
même un axe compliqué à gérer pour les
personnes seules les personnes en hôtel
les familles monoparentales les
personnes qui peuvent pas trop bouger de
chez elles qui sont déjà handicapées ou
fragilisées compas forcément de lien
familial ou qu'on pas forcément des bons
contacts pour x raisons avec leur
voisinage difficulté de comprendre la
langue et tout ça et donc du coup on
essaye quand même de maintenir des lieux
de vie aussi ouvert on va dans nos appel
à bénévoles dans nos propositions de
missions demandé aux aux gens qui se
propose que s'ils se sentent en capacité
d'apporter un soutien sur l'aide aux
devoirs on les mettra en lien avec une
personne car l'expérience au secours
populaire nous de prendre un contact en
premier avec les la personne qui se
proposent pour s'assurer quand même que
c'est une démarche sérieuse avec une
personne qui a un minimum de compétences
et tout ça et après on proposera un une
mise en relation
donc ça ça va me prendre peut-être un
petit peu de temps puisque ça va amener
ces sites est de démultiplier et ça peut
être gourmand bénévoles aussi d'autres
associations c'est bien sûr engagés dans
le département c'est le cas de la croix
rouge française des yvelines interview à
retrouver dans notre édition de vendredi
les collectivités également sur le pied
de guerre en ce moment les yvelines
maintiennent ouvert leurs établissements
départementaux relatif au social et à la
santé mais sous certaines conditions
lé centres de pmi ou les rendez vous
pour la vaccination et consultation des
enfants le suivi et des femmes enceintes
sont assurés en ce moment les centres de
planification et d'éducation familiale
ou encore les secteurs d'action sociale
sont également concernés en tout ce sont
24 sites répartis dans le département
qui restent opérationnels avec forcément
une adaptation nécessaire écouté le
directeur adjoint aux solidarités du
département des yvelines
nous avons des commandes et tous les
rendez nous qui n'était pas prioritaire
nous avons également fait passer les
mets
cette façon que des personnes qu'ils
soient malades ou qui présentent un
certain nombre de signes ne viennent pas
effectivement consultation nous avons
également espaces et les temps de
consultation pour éviter que les
personnes ne se croisent et nous avons
également doubler nos accueils civique
en matière de santé de conseil
téléphonique avec une centrale d'écouté
qui fonctionne et qui peut basculer donc
les interrogations des questions où les
inquiétudes qui peuvent avoir des gens
des parents sur tel ou tel sujet des
adolescents sur des personnes habilitées
qui la raconte et les accueils
téléphoniques restent ouverts de numéro
qui s'affiche pour la protection
maternelle et infantile et
l'accompagnement social
si vous nous suivez régulièrement vous
savez que chaque mercredi nous allons
dans les salles de cinéma du territoire
pour connaître la programmation de la
semaine confinement oblige c'est une
sélection de films à voir directement
depuis votre canapé que nous vous
proposons ce soir et segal pino
responsable du cinéma le grenier à sel à
trappes qui vous livre ses quelques
coûte que regardez moi je vais vous
donner des conseils de films qui m'ont
marqué qui m'ont beaucoup plu déjà le
premier film auquel je pense c'est
little big man c'est un jeune américain
de 1970 de l'arthur peine c'était le
réalisateur de bonnie and clyde on
retrouve dans le film dastan hoffman et
faye et le web c'est un western et c'est
un western qui bouleverse le genre
puisque les indiens ne sont pas vus
comme des sauvages dans ce film ils sont
vus au contraire des victimes de la
conquête de l'ouest est donc l'histoire
du film on suit l'histoire de jack cram
en 1970 jacques ramassant 21 ans et il
raconte toute son histoire et c'est
intéressant parce que c'est un jeune en
blanc qui va être élevé par des
cheyennes qui va ensuite devenir roi de
la gâchette qui va ensuite participé aux
grandes batailles little big horn et
conflit et donc en 1977 et une critique
flagrante de la guerre du vietnam
donc c'est un film qui est à la fois
drôle et émouvant et moi je le conseille
de le voir en version française puisque
ça rajoute une touche
d'humour supplémentaires la vf est assez
drôle
voilà donc c'est little big man avec
dustin hoffman mon autre conseil c'est
était une fois en amérique c'est aussi
un film américain c'est aussi une grande
fresque sur l'histoire de l'amérique
puisque c'est un film qui date de 1984
qui a été réalisé par sergio leone avec
un robert de niro
c'est d'ailleurs le tout dernier film de
sergio leone et on va suivre l'histoire
de noodles joué par de niro de la
prohibition jusqu'aux années 60 dont 45
ans de cette histoire de ce mafieux du
ghetto juif sa décadence et la grande
histoire avec ses amis mafieux sergio
leone s'est encore fait accompagner par
un humour écoles on retire ta musique
notamment grandiose le film a été
restauré en 2012 il est ressorti à
cannes à ce moment là et il ya des
scènes rajoutées ces décès n'ont jamais
eu des scènes inédites
elles ont été retrouvées sur un support
un peu particulier et ils n'ont pas
réussi à les restaurer la même manière
donc quand on voit la version actuelle
du film il y à des scènes qui sont
beaucoup plus moche et qui en français
ne sont pas doublés donc c'est le destin
qui ne sont en vo avec une qualité de
soins de qualité d'image de couleurs qui
sont vraiment différents c'était donc il
était une fois en amérique de sergio
leone
c'est les deux conseils que je vous
donnais mais vous aussi vous orienter
sur le site du cnc le cnc le centre
national du cinéma qui gère le cinéma
les films les salles de cinéma etc et
îlots à moteur de référencement pour les
la vidéo à distance
il y à toutes les offres légales
évidemment pour voir des films à la
demande et pour les enfants je ne
saurais que vous conseiller d'aller voir
le site banshee et e n est-ce pas ch'ti
banshee point fr et accès à des fiches
d'accompagnement des films il y as et
conseils de films pour les tranches
d'âge de 3 à 10 ans et il ya une partie
payante qui est la vidéo à la demande ou
tous les défis qui sont sélectionnés qui
sont des courts métrages de longs
métrages et vous pouvez laisser vos
enfants tranquillement à la suite
puisque vous êtes pour toute sécurité
donc c'est banshee point fr tous ces
autres et cela je les mettrai sur le
site du cinéma cinémas grenier à sel
point fr
la fin de cette édition spéciale merci
de votre fidélité on se quitte sur ces
images le secteur du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à montigny le
bretonneux vide de ces passants habituel
restez chez vous et belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à